um
[Música]
madrid-
marisela píxels se reforzarán largas
efe
de un porque el centro del campo sanford
[Aplausos]
[Música]
situaciones difíciles
encontraste muertos en el fondo de la
patera tenemos que sacar y lo que
conlleva eso no lo llevas para adentro
pues posiblemente lo padezca más ahora
mismo que en el momento del momento al
final lo asumen los con ese subidón de
adrenalina hacen lo que tienes que hacer
luego no piensas en lo que has hecho y
ahora por ejemplo me estás preguntando
[Música]
yo también se presentará esperando de la
muerte pero hay mucha gente viste todos
son muertos nosotros también en poder
presentar esperando de la muerte
[Música]
lo que yo te voy a decirle a un familiar
es que su familiar ha muerto porque
mientras que el cuerpo no aparezca
no tenemos certeza de que la persona
haya fallecido entonces yo no puedo
decirle a un familiar que me llama desde
marruecos desde senegal que su familiar
ha muerto lo que sí le puedo decir es
que en los lugares donde debería estar
no está
[Música]